[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
hallo liebe Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer
hier sind wir wieder Mirko Kasimir und
Stefan Netzeband wir erzählen euch heute
von einer Frau die mich wirklich zu
Tiefs beeindruckt hat und ich möchte an
dieser Stelle waren dieser Fall ist
nichts für schwache Nerven diese Frau
hat überlebt aber was ihr angetan wurde
ist unbeschreiblich grausam hört euch
diese Folge also bitte nicht oder
zumindest nicht alleine an z.B wenn ihr
schwanger seid oder euch Gewalt an
Schwangeren zu sehr belasten könnte ihr
seid hier mit gewarnt bitte Mirko lass
uns anfangen
[Musik]
Washington DC Anfang Dezember 2009 dafür
dass Winter ist sind die Tage noch
relativ warm deutlich über 0 Grad doch
sie werden kälter und obwohl der Winter
mit seinem grauen eisigen Gesicht für
viele eine harte Zeit ist für die
29-Jährige TK Adams ist es ein Winter
voller Hoffnung
Kika war schon als Teenager von zu Hause
abgehauen und lebt jahrelang auf der
Straße irgendwann aber zieht sie
immerhin in einen Obdachlosenheim sie
nimmt sich sogar vor noch einen
Schulabschluss zu machen und sie
verliebt sich in einen tollen jungen
Mann namens PJ die beiden heiraten sogar
als Tiger schwanger wird darf sie in ein
Mutter-Kind-Heim umziehen aber schon
bald will sie mit PJ zusammen wohnen sie
ist in diesem milden dezember 2009 im
letzten im 9 Schwangerschaftsmonat und
es scheint als wäre das Universum mal
auf ihrer Seite Tiger hält Anrufe von
einer unterdrückten Nummer als sie
schließlich rangeht meldet sich eine
Frau namens der Familie Milz sie arbeite
für eine Wohltätigkeitsorganisation und
habe Babykleidung für Sie Kika solle
vorbeikommen und sie sich anschauen
Tiger ist euphorisch als ihrem Mann von
dem Telefonat erzählt versucht er sie zu
bremsen er warnt sie du kennst diese
Frau nicht stört sich nicht in etwas von
dem du nichts genaues weißt
Tikka nimmt seine Sorgen nicht ernst die
Frau klang so nett am Telefon sie muss
und will diese Chance nutzen
Stefanie holt Adams ab gemeinsam fahren
sie zu ihrem Apartment ab diesem Moment
sitzt TK in der Falle
sie ahnt noch nicht wie bitter ernst
dieser lockere wohltätige Ausflug mit
der so freundlichen Sozialarbeiterin
werden wird etwas seltsam ist dass
Stephanies Apartment nur spartanisch
eingerichtet ist naja hat sie nicht
gesagt dass es eine Art Lager ist denkt
die Schwangere Adams vielleicht noch
bloß nicht verrückt machen diese Frau
will mir ja nur helfen was dann passiert
schildertika später in einem
Fernsehinterview für das englische
Format Eis survive also ich überlebte
kam geboren
ich mache das mir bequem die Kamera rein
und machte einen Film an dann rief mich
mein Mann an und sagte Mann wo bist du
jetzt ich sagte mir geht's gut denn zu
diesem Zeitpunkt wusste ich wirklich
nicht mehr wo ich bin nachdem mit meinem
Mann aufgelegt hatte saßen wir da und
unterhielten uns und sie machte precious
an es war eine Raubkopie des Films und
wir sahen ihn uns an und plötzlich warf
sie mir diese schwere Steppdecke über
den Hinterkopf und fing an mir auf den
Kopf zu schlagen nachdem sie mich etwa
zehnmal geschlagen hatte bin ich
aufgesprungen und habe meine Hände
hochgeworfen in einer schützenden
Bewegung fürs Gesicht und alles was ich
sehen konnte war Blut ich rannte aus dem
Schlafzimmer und rannte zur vor der Tür
aber die vor der Tür war verriegelt mit
dem Türschloss dem Kettenschloss und
einem bodenschloss zu diesem Zeitpunkt
war sie mir schon auf den Rücken
gesprungen und wir kämpfen miteinander
ich rang mit dieser 216 Pfund schweren
Frauen das überall Blut ich kann nicht
wirklich sehen meine Augenbrennen mein
Kopf hämmert und sie versucht mir die
Hände auf den Mund zu legen und mich zu
würgen und ich wehre mich so gut ich
kann und plötzlich nimmt sie dieses
schwere Stadtteil in die Hand es ist
lang es ist ein Feuerhaken für den Kamin
und sie schwang er und schwanger sein
einfach sie muss mich fast 40 mal auf
den Kopf geschlagen haben und ich wurde
ohnmächtig
immer hell dann wird alles schwarz
als sie wieder wach wird ist sie mit
Klebeband gefesselt drei Tage liegt
Adams auf einer Matratze nichts passiert
sie ist Stefanies Geisel wehrlos
verwundet und schwanger wann wird dieser
Albtraum aufhören wird sie es überhaupt
lebend herausschaffen was hat Stefanie
geplant die kündigt nur kryptisch an ich
will dich nicht töten ich habe etwas
anderes mit dir vor aber was das wird
Tiger schon am nächsten Tag erfahren und
wenn sie gewusst hätte was mit ihr
geschehen wird hätte sie vielleicht
gebetet einfach gleich zu sterben
Handtücher eine Schale mit eiskaltem
Wasser und ein Messer
Stefanie platziert diese Dinge neben der
gefesselten und jetzt panischen
Schwangeren sie will mich foltern denkt
Adams doch es kommt viel schlimmer ihre
Peinigerin offenbart ihr nun nach vier
Tagen Ungewissheit und Todes Angst den
grausamen Plan sie werde tikas Bauch
aufschneiden um das Baby rauszuholen für
Adams beginnt nur der eigentliche Kampf
um ihr Leben um das Leben ihres Kindes
um ihre Familie
ohne Betäubung oder Schmerzmittel setzt
Stefanie das Messer an die Schmerzen
sind unerträglich so unerträglich dass
Tiger den Entschluss fast ruhig liegen
zu bleiben das alles über sich ergehen
zu lassen wenn sie sich bewegt tut alles
nur noch mehr weh
stundenlang zieht sich die Tortur bis
Stefanie glaubt ihr Ziel gleich erreicht
zu haben sie verkündet ich habe deine
Fruchtblase angeschnitten ich brauche
nur noch hineingreifen und das Kind
rausholen willst du dass ich es jetzt
gleich mache oder willst du eine Pause
Kika wird durch den großen Blutverlust
bewusstlos als sie wieder zu sich kommt
ist alles still das Baby ist doch in
ihrem Bauch ist der vernie schläft wenn
sie es lebend aus dieser Wohnung
schaffen möchte dann ist dieser Moment
ihre einzige Chance
als ich über ihren Körper trat tropfte
das Blut aus meinem Bauch und kleinen
Tropfen auf die Decke und ich bin jetzt
wie eine Maus und geben von Katzen und
ich stecke einfach fest ich war mit
einem Fuß über ihr und mit dem anderen
hinter ihr und weil ich unter Schock
stehe denke ich hoffentlich bewegt sie
sich nicht ich hoffe möglich dass sie
sich nicht bewegt aber sie hat sich
nicht bewegt dann bin ich mit meinem
anderen Fuß über sie gestiegen und jetzt
arbeite ich mich durch den Flur zur
Eingangstür vor als ich dann in der
Mitte des Flurs ankomme fällt mein
ganzer Bauch hinter der Haut hervor
meine Eingeweide alles kommt einfach
raus und jetzt halte ich meinen Bauch
wie einen Fußball ich halte mich an der
Wand fest und laufe einfach und ich
versuche nicht schwer zu atmen nicht
atme einfach langsam während ich gehe
denn jeder Schritt ist ein Schmerz dann
habe ich angefangen die Tür aufzusperren
alle Schlösser ganz langsam ganz ruhig
und als ich die Tür öffnete machte sie
eine Art knarrendes Geräusch in meiner
Augen
sie schleppt sich den Gang entlang immer
dann Türen schreit um Hilfe niemand
öffnet die kann nimmt die Treppe nach
oben bricht noch auf den Stufen völlig
erschöpft zusammen aber
sie hört endlich Schritte auf Sie
zukommen aber es ist nicht die Hilfe die
sie jetzt so sehr gebrauchen könnte es
ist Stefanie bereits sie zurück in die
Hölle zu schleifen aus der sie gerade
geflohen ist der zweite Überlebenskampf
beginnt Tika wehrt sich beißt schreit
tritt um sich und plötzlich ist er da
dieser Mann ein Nachbar der den Krach
gehört hat er will wissen was vor sich
geht Stefanie erklärt die Frau sei
verrückt brauche Hilfe Sie Stefanie
kümmere sich Kika sagt immer wieder sie
versucht mich zu töten als der Nachbar
den offenen Bauch sieht rennt er zurück
in seine Wohnung am 6 dezember 2009 um
8:52 Uhr geht seinen Notruf bei der
Polizei des Prinz George County ein
[Musik]
TK wird in ein Krankenhaus gebracht ob
Ihr Baby überhaupt noch lebt weiß sie zu
diesem Zeitpunkt nicht ob sie selbst es
schaffen wird auch nicht
TK Adams wird notoperiert
schafft es der Moment in dem sie ihre
Augen wieder öffnet und realisiert dass
sie in Sicherheit ist lebt muss ich wie
ein Wunder angefühlt haben doch das
eigentliche Wunder wartet noch auf sie
es ist ein Kern gesundes lebendiges
Wunder mit winzigen Händen die nach der
Wärme ihrer Mutter suchen wie sich
während der OP rausstellt hat Stephanie
nie die Fruchtblase geöffnet sie schnitt
stattdessen versehentlich tikas Blase
durch schlimm genug aber entscheidend
dann nachdem die Fruchtblase ja
vermeintlich geöffnet wurde hat der
Familie sich in falscher Sicherheit
gewogen und eine Pause eingelegt dazu
kommt dass das Kind sich recht weit oben
im Bauch ja man kann fast schon sagen
zusammen gekauert hat diese Umstände
haben beiden das Leben gerettet wie du
sagst ein Wunder und genauso nennt sie
ihr Kind dann auch miracle aber was ist
mit Stefanie
nachdem der Nachbar die Polizei
alarmiert hat ist sie abgehauen am
nächsten Tag meldet sie sich bei den
Beamten und verrät Ihnen Ihren
Aufenthaltsort Stefanie wird wenig
später verhaftet obwohl eigentlich wird
Veronica de Remmers verhaftet so heißt
die damals 40-Jährige nämlich wirklich
Sozialarbeiterin ist sie auch nicht
früher diente sie beim Militär es stellt
sich auch heraus dass ihr 17 Jahre alter
Sohn Derrick über alles Bescheid wusste
und sich sogar in der Wohnung befand
laut Gerichtsunterlagen hat er seiner
Mutter beim Fesseln geholfen er war auch
derjenige der nach Kickers Flucht seine
Mutter geweckt hat um sie zu informieren
dass die Schwangere nicht mehr da sein
er weiß der die fluchttasche packte
während seine Mutter mit der schwer
verletzten auf den Treppenstufen kämpfte
ganz schwierige Rolle als Sohn hörst du
auf deine Mutter das ist ja auch das ist
deine Mama die liebst du aber in dem
Moment als er den offenen Bauch gesehen
hat tja was da in ihm vorgegangen sein
muss will ihn ja nicht in Schutz nehmen
den jungen Kerl aber wahrscheinlich der
Schock wird der Fall ist vor Gericht
gelandet wie ging es denn da weiter
Veronicas Anwalt plädiert auf Freispruch
die Angeklagte sei nicht schuldfähig die
Verteidigung geht sogar so weit zu
behaupten Adams hätte mit ihr einen Deal
abgeschlossen demnach soll erdems 5000 $
für das Baby erhalten haben tja was ist
denn das bitte für ein Quatsch erstens
warum legte sich dann eine Schein
Identität zu zweitens warum hat sie dann
vor Tiger das Baby auf diese brutale
Weise richtig aus dem Körper zu
schneiden statt auf die Geburt zu warten
die ja ohnehin bald bevorstanden hätte
also das ganze ist ein absolut faule und
auch finde ich ekelhafte Ausrede da
stimme ich dir auf jeden Fall zu Stefan
auch für Tiger war das zu viel nach
dieser Aussage ist sie nämlich im
Gericht einfach durchgedreht sie ist
wutendbrannt von ihrem Platz
aufgesprungen über ihren Sitz geklettert
und hat sich auf die Ramos gestürzt sie
angeschrien und angebrüllt und versucht
sie zu schlagen der Sicherheitsdienst
konnte Schlimmeres verhindern Kika wurde
raus eskortiert zu einem Schuldspruch
wegen versuchten Mordes was lebenslange
Haft und in den USA heißt das wirklich
lebenslang bedeuten könnte kommt es
nicht denn es gibt keine Beweise dafür
dass Veronika Tica töten wollte am Ende
des Prozesses bekennt sie sich der
schweren Körperverletzung für schuldig
Veronika der Ramos wird im Winter 2010
zu 25 Jahren Haft verurteilt
2022 aber wurde Veronica de Ramos auf
Bewährung entlassen
und was wurde wohl aus Kika und ihre
Hoffnung dass jetzt alles besser würde
das ist immerhin ein Happy End Tiger ist
nicht mehr obdachlos sie wohnt jetzt mit
ihrem Mann und ihrer Tochter in einem
Haus obwohl ihr Traum von noch mehr
Kindern nicht mehr erfüllbar ist sagt
Kika dass sie sich durch all das was sie
in ihrem Leben durchgemacht hat stärker
fühlt insofern ist diese
Horrorgeschichte auch eine Geschichte
über eine tolle starke Frau
[Musik]
das war die Geschichte von TK Adams wir
danken euch dass ihr heute wieder mit
dabei wart gebt uns gern ein Feedback
per Instagram oder via Mail die Links
dazu findet ihr wie immer in den Show
Notes bis zum nächsten mal euer Mirko
und euer Stefan den Fall TK Adams haben
wir unter anderem mit Hilfe von Artikeln
der BZ NBC Washington cbsnews daily Male
und Ausschnitten der Serie 5 machen
erzählt redakt
Postproduktion weight watch Studios
München